dude what Freck is going on we've had
some crazy stories hit the hit the old
desk
lately yesterday we had the guy that
mentored Steve Jobs and today we have
some insane leaked DMS from Kevin Zhang
the e-commerce King you may remember him
he says he's putting the fake gurus out
of business for all of you gurus and
self-proclaimed experts out there and
you better watch out but the actual
truth is maybe something completely
different guys today we're going inside
the mind of a fake guru normally we're
from the outside looking in today we
finally get a look at what these people
actually think of their business of you
guys and you know it will shock you
honestly it surprised even me I I don't
have that high of an opinion of a lot of
fake gurus but let's just say even I was
stunned but before we get into that I
want to say a few things about these DMS
and the topics surrounding it
specifically the Kevins surrounding it
guys you have to understand something
coffee Zilla it's a no bullying zone
okay you guys know that these gurus are
always trying to say hey he's bullying
me he's you know we saw this with
Baltimore you know Kevin Baltimore and
then we have Baltimore once again asking
hey guys did everyone report it for
hateful content or abusive content been
bullying please reply yes you did we
want to make sure to try to get it
removed but now we're seeing this may be
happening with Kevin Xing as well we're
you know ecommerce baller the original
guy who busted Kevin Zeng and I made a
follow-up video pointing back to his
video his videos deleted now for cyber
bullying and harassment in fact his
whole channel too wiped out because
YouTube's agreed with you know whoever
reported it and said hey this is cyber
bullying and harassment for reporting on
a scam which is so strange by the way
that were the ones you know on this side
of the table having to make sure that
we're not cyber bullying people who are
literally taking other people's money a
lot of times using lines how is it that
I'm worried about being too offensive
when they can just say hey you can make
millions of dollars online is so easy
and then I'm in trouble for saying hey
this guy's plagiarizing stuff hey this
it's absolutely bizarre to me but I
guess YouTube wants to be happy fun
times all the time so let me be clear
once and for all this video is not
attacking Kevin saying at all everything
in here will be strictly about how he
treats his customers and what you need
to know as a potential buyer of Kevin's
eggs course this is a consumer rights
issue here look trust me there was a lot
more than what I'm about to show you in
these DMS but a lot of it was personal
and to be honest I don't really care to
get into the personal stuff with Kevin's
eggs life what we care about here on
coffee Zillah are the parts that impact
you as a consumer no bullying harassment
going on here YouTube but secondly I
also want to say that you know these
DIMMs were not leaked by me they were
leaked initially by an insider and then
they were brought to light by e-commerce
baller who made a whole video about it
but it's important you guys know I'm not
just taking these demons at face value
we went through extensive lengths to try
to verify the existence of these DMS and
that they were from the people they were
say they were from allegedly these
conversations happened between a few
people most notably kevin zhang and a
business partner and there's also a
conversation between kevin zhang and all
of us now the biggest thing that we're
worried about here is number one giving
Kevin Zhang the right to prove that
these are not from him and to actually
proving that this person this insider
actually had real insight knowledge I
mean if you guys are bored I'll leave a
little time stamp to jump to the juicy
DMS okay
but I want to show you guys that we're
doing our due diligence here it's
important so the first thing we did was
we reached out to Kevin saying seven
days ago and gave him the chance to
respond no response
number two the way we verified these DMS
was we contacted baller Buster's and
allegedly there was a conversation
between them according to the insider
and I went and I validated that that
conversation happened exactly as this
insider said it happened so after
verifying that that conversation
happened exactly as the the screenshot
said it happened we were able to realize
that okay this person obviously has
access to Kevin Singh's accounts so the
rest of his conversations are real as
well but by also giving Kevin saying a
platform to defend himself on even
though he chose not to use it we allowed
for the possibility that maybe we were
even wrong there too now let's jump into
what these diems actually say the first
thing I want to show you guys is this
this is a conversation
between Kevin Zhang and a business
partner named Raoul I've blocked out his
last name because I don't think it's
really relevant in this DM Raoul shows a
screenshot and says did you cook this up
and it's a success story okay so already
it's there's this hilarious implication
that they're cooking up fake
testimonials from people of their big
you know successes but then Kevin goes
nah hahaha it was the Mexican kid bro
it's crazy and the guy's basically
talking about how much money he's making
with the e-commerce and so they're in
disbelief that any of their students
succeeded
no way I can't believe he's 1 for 1 and
we're 0 for 9
ok first up I told you we're starting
with the big stuff this is a guy who
claims to have made 20 million dollars
in e-commerce and yet here he is behind
the scenes
saying that this kid who's achieved some
success is 1 for 1 so he's actually
succeeding and there's 0 for 9 the
people teaching you a course are
admitting behind the scenes that there's
0 for 9 as far as wins 2 losses they
keep losing businesses but then it gets
better cuz Raul says $400 a day in like
shock they say what's his niche can we
steal it which is the most insane thing
to say about a student that you're
helping right these people are saying
hey buy your course we're gonna teach
you how to do this thing then when you
actually succeed they go gosh I can't
believe you succeeded we keep failing at
this thing we're supposedly teaching and
then he goes can we steal that guy's I
get our winning student that the guy
against all odds they can't believe it
they say it did we cook this up because
we can't believe that someone succeed
succeed can we steal his success oh no
yeah this is the psychology of a fake
guru that I'm telling you guys about
that I keep warning you about this guy's
succeeding let's steal it and yes of
course yes it gets worse I don't know if
you guys remember but Kevin Zhuang was
at one time a member of the Forbes
Business Council which he still has
advertised but I think since my videos
come out since my ecommerce ballers
videos come out they've actually removed
for whatever reason but one of the
things I always say is that people are
buying their way into Forbes that when
they say I can't believe I got into Ford
oh my gosh they just they just realized
how successful I am they're actually
paying Forbes to put them in and then
pretending to be shocked when Forbes
puts them in even though they paid for
it which is like the lamest thing ever
to do for this commercial that I
basically made for myself so you guys
see that all the time with these fake
gurus right well here's concrete proof
from Kevin Zeng inside a discord group
that these people are paying for it okay
they're paying PR teams in this thing
here's him sinks I paid for a PR team
that got me into Forbes then Kevin thing
underneath that so does every public
figure or celebrity guys first of all
shame on you for for letting that happen
but also you should never trust a Forbes
feature again ever if anyone says they
got into fourth you should assume they
paid for it because obviously a Kevin
Zane's not the only one to do this I
mean he definitely did it but he's not
the only one these people these
ecommerce people they're paying for
basically fake social proof um from
Forbes and this guy's out of your sink
so does every public figure or
celebrities guys we still have even more
because you guys may be wondering you
know what do these guys think of me they
always say how thankful they are but
here we have we have a conversation that
says the exact opposite bro but me I've
been talking to this for an hour he
doesn't stop asking questions think
Kevin Zayn lmao I hate this constituent
services says Kevin Zhuang Raoul I can't
believe you do this every day entertain
these holes and the worst part is he's
asking these questions bro look guys
this is insane this is how they think of
you guys behind the scenes and they
refer to people as Cox multiple times
that's kind of they're just word for you
just remember like when they're publicly
saying hey man I love you guys love you
guys
I'm here for you they're tired of you
asking questions okay but now I don't
want to tell you guys about something
else that truly sickened me to my
stomach thinking about all the people
that are gonna get scammed and thinking
about the livelihoods of people who fall
for this stuff because in here they're
complaining about the fact that courses
are hard to sell these days I hope it
wasn't because of me and now they're
trying to move to something else right
so Kevin's eggs in here and he's talking
about the fact that you know this guy
clever investor another youtuber says
courses are terrible but his private
group is way too Opie even though he
breaks even on his Real Estate's it's
all about the paid groups right now
that comes with retreats and and this is
my favorite moment right here because
then Raoul says huh paid retreats and
stuff you're offering people paid
retreat he goes hey Kevin but we need
people who are already successful that
is a bombshell guys are you looking at
what I'm looking at we need people who
are already successful translation all
our people who are buying a course are
broke this is what I've been saying they
prey on broke people this is in black
and white admitting it we need people
who are successful Kevin we don't have
people who are successful with it's a
change in clientele so they can afford
the four times yearly travel
Kevin Zhuang story can bait a bunch of
[ __ ] nah it's just $100 a month
aka poor people can pay for this private
group Raoul says but will poor Cox
travel in other words again their
demographic the people they're targeting
will are poor demographic travel which
you know because the idea is you bait up
with these retreats you say hey we're
gonna go on these epic retreats guys
he'll come join my group my $100 a month
group and then Kevin saying here says
nah Raoul but a hundred dollars we don't
need content Kevin saying he said no one
actually goes to the retreats oh my gosh
you're offering a retreat knowing that
none of your viewers can pay for it but
they don't get them all excited guys the
level of predatory here is almost hard
to describe this validates everything
I've been saying these people know
exactly what they're doing beyond a
shadow of a doubt they're talking about
the fact that hey
that this strategy might requires to
actually have rich people who can afford
our thing we can't do that Kevin thing
saying no no it's okay we can still use
these poor suckers that we've been
attracting all along and they'll just do
it they just won't go on the retreats no
one does it's a part of the strategy
that no one goes on these retreats
absolutely insane now guys we're gonna
kind of have to leave it right there
those are the big teams that I want to I
wanted to share with you guys but let's
recap guys the in case you missed the
bombshells because there's so much here
number one be paid to get into Forbes
they talk openly about stealing their
customers success they complain very
loudly about how much you guys ask them
questions they don't like being asked
questions you guys are a bunch of [ __ ]
and of course maybe the worst of all
they are talking very openly about how
they know you're you're poor the people
they're targeting they call you a poor
[ __ ] you're not just a [ __ ] your poor
[ __ ] and they're after you they don't
want those rich [ __ ] how are they gonna
get those this video is never gonna be
monetized visit may be poor [ __ ]
disgusting stuff but I'm really happy
this happened because we went inside the
mind of a guru and into the mind of
these the types of people who purposely
prey on poor people to make their money
it's really something thank you so much
for stopping by checking us out we've
got more investigations on the way we've
got a real jobs on the way we've got
amazing content planned for you so I'm
so excited to share that with you thanks
for watching and go check out baller
Buster who will be reposting this video
probably along with some funny
commentary he was super helpful with you
know validating some of these things as
you guys well know
I'll also be linking ecommerce ballers
new channel after he got his first one
deleted in the comment section below and
also in the description subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
for the car
[Music]